when uh you went to Vegas for your first
time ever we all we all went out on this
trip to Las Vegas you'd never seen it
and you'd think like here's this is
Vinnie's opportunity to to show you
something you've never seen before to
take you on a romantic date to go like
Walk The Strip see the sites and Vinnie
treated you to a trip to a shoe store so
that you could watch him by
himself yeah I remember that it was
actually you that said it too you're
like why are you not bringing her out to
go do these things you got a hot chick
on your arm in Vegas and you take her to
[__] yourself a pair of
shoes hey babe this place thing got sick
hype hype beasts in
balances hype Beast inbalance dude all
right I'm not going to okay let's
I I'm not going to make up excuses and
try to justify any of this whatsoever
but
but it I've never really been in a
relationship with somebody who I like
genuinely care about right for like ever
honestly you know what I mean so it's
like I really
laughing so you would think that this
being your first time you'd be
overwhelmed with just a helicopter ride
around the [__] Grand Canyon dude
[__]
hey
stordy for mecking get me hell you're
not making a good argument it's like if
this is the first time like I
can't the first time about she's all I
think about all I want to do is just
take her go watch me buy a pair of shoes
I was going to buy her a pair too I was
I asked her I asked her she says no I
don't wear these are the first Nikes
that I have and they're cuz of you he
bought a year later he bought me shoes
okay now on the topic of your hype Beast
shoe habit yeah is it alarming or
concerning to you Autumn what a
disproportional amount of
Vinnie's funds income income is allotted
is allotted to his hype Beast end
balances that is dunks and his like
right like I mean I I'll argue on this
one all day I do not I do not spend a
crazy amount of money on shoes everybody
thinks so I mean it's hard to imagine
you do spend a lot but I mean as long as
we have like a house in the car yeah I
make sure I have a good amount of money
in my savings account I make sure the
bills are paid I make sure there's food
in the fridge I make sure everything is
[__] good hey hey and and if your
ladies quot it then yeah I don't like I
spend I really I don't spend money like
you know I don't right I don't um but I
like spending money like I read a lot of
books so a lot of my things so if he
were to make me feel bad about why like
that's a stupid hobby you know I mean it
is a little more productive than shoes
but I if he were to make me feel bad
about that I'd be like well that's
something I like to do and it makes me
happy so I don't make him feel bad if I
again if I was noticing like our funds
were just really low but do you have an
eye on that do you have like do you know
what your funds are have you guys like
we haven't opened a book Jo no we
haven't yet but she can look at my
phones anytime she no no but like I mean
she she can look at his FS they in his
closet
yeah I can do but isn't that like
something that's important for like a
like two becomes one so you guys are
going to mingle funds yeah absolutely
and are you better are you better at
spending money or is Vinnie better at
spending money no I I really don't spend
money I she's so low maintenance it's
crazy and are you high maintenance he's
so high my mom even says she always ask
me with the wedding she's like how's the
future bride doing and I'm like oh I'm
good she's like no not you
Vinnie manage he just wants all these
things he was trying to rent like a
Rolls-Royce for the wedding I was like
you don't cuz it would look sick in
pictures I know like an old school
oldfashioned Rolls-Royce for a few hours
you know sick yeah um so uh but we want
to make sure this marriage lasts so is
there anything that Vinnie does that
like you don't like that we can like air
out now that you guys are arguing about
because like I feel like you got a catch
here Vinnie I know I do you don't want
to [__] it up know and I feel like I'm
gonna say you know when we did the big
shoot at my house I was gonna bring that
up too but you probably because you
weren't even there for this part of I
heard about this when I gave you a call
I called you directly and I said hey man
like it sounds like you were uh you know
egregiously lacking self-awareness and
in and very inconsiderate of your lady
when we had this shoot at the house are
you picking up on social cues from your
girl when she's on the couch like
and you're like what dude I got I have
to go into the jacuzzi and get my for 15
minutes but I went I was going into the
jacuzzi while the footage was dropping
the footage was dropping footage was
dropping the footage was dropping I got
to get in the jacuzzi for my 15 minutes
of me
time yeah I just want 15 minutes of
myself you took no no no no no okay
listen best friend in town listen no no
no no I was going in and out of the ju
jacuzzi while the footage was dropping
and then also the footage 11 minutes ago
and I had a business meeting a little
thing that I was doing I was supposed to
go do that never happed yeah thank God I
had a business meeting and I just had to
get my 15 minutes of
me be ready for it okay I'm not like I'm
not going to make excuses or
justification for like my shitty actions
but but but but Autumn like but that's
not the only time this has happened
right right no it was a consistent thing
I always say at the beginning of the
relationship I'm not going to lie it was
like I had a very hard time not because
you're like no no no not cuz you're like
a horrible boyfriend but like you just
you haven't been in relationships like
at all they' been like two months you
know so I just it's hard to be with
someone like that who hasn't been in
relationships because they really lack
like that self-awareness and they're
like at times they can be selfish
because they're not used to being you
know but I'm someone like I've been in
like fouryear relationships I've lived
with people you know what I mean so I've
have that so I know like not to be
selfish but he just didn't really but I
think genuinely the last time like when
you called when it was like coming from
a third party like looking up being like
dude like that's I think that's when it
was kind of his wakeup call um because
there was times where it would get
better and then you know it would
decline um but I think like someone else
being like this is you know well see
like I am a
particularly self-absorbed like you know
[__] and and I know how much work
that I have to do for my relationship
ship everyone does yeah's perfect
just just
kidding I'm totally kidding I I know I I
just know how how much I come up short
and and I'm aware of it you know and so
I know that it takes a lot of work and
so my concern with Vinnie was that like
he's not even necessarily aware of it
you know like yeah you know and you're
right at the time I really wasn't that
aware of it but now it's the new Vinnie
yes all right so does autumn do anything
thing that that bugs you no I really
don't think so sorry I'm going to answer
for you so don't [__] this up I know
okay let me ask you this she let me say
this she puts up with my [__] very well
and she understands that um like the
goals that I have and dreams that I have
and she lets me [__] do all these
things without question yeah and that
means more to me than anything you know
so I'm I'm a shitthead sometimes are you
gonna cry at your wedding I don't he's
going to cry I have a bet that he's
going to cry on the alar he is a cry
you're a lot more emotional than I am
yeah I'm very emotional for sure do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude